plus de 4000 atteintes entiers lgbt+
enregistré en France par les forces de
l'ordre l'an dernier soit 3% de plus
qu'en 2021 des agressions qui se
produisent toujours en 2023 comme en
témoigne les multiples dégradations et
l'attaque qui ont visé le centre LGBTI
de Touraine la ministre chargée de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et de la diversité étaient à Tours
aujourd'hui pour apporter son soutien à
la communauté un déplacement visant
aussi à présenter les grands axes du
prochain plan national de lutte contre
la haine anti LGBT plus Florent Clavel
une visite hautement symbolique quelques
jours après l'arrestation de l'auteur
présumée des attaques contre le centre
LGBTI de Touraine la ministre à
l'égalité femme homme veut rassurer et
adressé un message de fermeté aux
auteurs d'actes
car si le calme est revenu l'inquiétude
persiste chez les militants soulager
néanmoins vigilant notre notre
association reste quand même vulnérable
à tous ces actes de vandalisme nous
l'avons vu au corps aujourd'hui et même
hier sur les passages arc-en-ciel de la
ville de Tours qui ont été une nouvelle
fois dégradée et c'est d'ailleurs c'est
hostilité de plus en plus affiché qui a
décidé Isabelle Longvic Rome à faire le
déplacement alors que ce profil la
Marche des fiertés samedi prochain la
ministre en a profité pour dresser les
grandes lignes d'un nouveau plan de
lutte contre la haine dans le tille
LGBTI qui sera dévoilé dans quelques
jours nous nous engageons à notamment à
renforcé pour les formations les
policiers et des gendarmes mais aussi de
tous les traditionnel de sécuriser
encore davantage les lieux qui sont qui
peuvent être
des lieux de risques d'agression et puis
de travailler aussi en termes de
prévention de sensibilisation et de
répression des mesures qui satisfont les
militants qui espèrent maintenant des
moyens supplémentaires pour accomplir
leur mission de sensibilisation dans les
écoles 1500 jeunes tours en jouant
rencontrés l'an dernier nous sommes
subventionnés cependant puisque notre
action grandit des subventions on
l'espère vont grandir avec pour qu'on
puisse accomplir le mieux possible cette
action qui est très importante qui est
la prévention du harcèlement des
discriminations dans les collèges et des
lycées présent également le préfet
d'Indre-et-Loire a annoncé le
renforcement de la sécurité pour la
Marche des fiertés à Tours entre 2 et
3000 personnes défileront samedi